Vìa bà mẹ chẳng vừa kì công biển số 20 sau ngày bà người tháng 3 năm nay như thủng trong ngày sau
về chánh chính công tác kính xuất rất mổ ra số người khác mộ ngành cơ quan Trung gương và đều phương
công biển của thủ đều chính phủ yêu cơ cần tăng cơ kính xuất rất mổ ra số
sử lĩnh nghiêm các vi phạm mà đảm ăn toàn thực phẩm, nâng cao thì loạt kì cương trong thực thí công vộ
công biển nước gió, thời gian qua, sẽ ra tình trạm thu góng, gần chuyển, rất mổ và tình thủ lượng vài những quy mô lớn tại một số địa phương
gây mất ăn toàn thực phẩm, làm ra tắc vì cơ lây lăng gì bệnh và anh vường đến những lực quan li nhà nước trong lực cuộc thủy
thu đếng yêu cầu chủ tệnh của bán nhân gân các tình thành phố chức thu gương, tăng cường công tác kìm chà găm sát
sử lĩ các cơ sở giết mổ, kìm xuất chả trẻ việc vận chuyển động vận sản phẩm động vận, sử lĩnh nghiêm các hành vý vị phạm và chất giận người đứng đầu, nếu đề sảy ra sai phạm,
thu tướng ra bộ nước giả bà mối trường chủ trì, phối hợp với các bộ ngành lên quan, tổ chức kìm chai chuyên đề về hạt động giết mổ, kìm xuất giết mổ trên phạm vị tòn quốc,
ra xuất phản thịn cơ chế khoản lĩ theo hướng khoản lĩ trối, phí xuất mổng gốc và khoản lĩ rử dò,
bộ công an tăng cường điều tra sự lĩnh nghiêm các hành vý vị phạm giêm chào của về kìm xuất giết mổ lượng vật,
làm lay lan dịch mạnh, người mất ăn quan thị phẩm, bây giờ bộ công thường được giáo sĩ trạc khoản lĩ thị trường,
bộ ý tế tăng cường kìm chạm quan thị phẩm, chân trình việc buông lòng kìm chạm toàn về sinh thị phẩm ở các nước ăn tập thế,
nhớt là trong các trường học, thu tướng cú yêu cầu để mạnh công tác thông tin chuyên, nhằm nâng cao chất giận của các tổ chức cá nhân trong sản xuất kìm xuân,
phổ biến giận người dân không sự dụng sản phẩm động vật không giống nguồn vô, không bao đam điều kiện về sinh thuis ăn quan thị phẩm,
mân gà nhận tức trường phẩm ở dưới ra.